mr. purselley memphis public pretty
offices guess maybe I'm just creeping
for destiny laundering agenda and just
to give everybody an idea of what the
hand is 14 darling
lots of favorites medium oh dear I've
got a question between two the relevant
people that implies government could
ensure that they have opportunity to
answer all the pressures we had fully
gradually promotions and leader to do so
but only everybody else has received
copy of opening from the hex on pedal
through publication and those will be
asked and will be addressed in Anton in
public and will probably throw the
question in from the committee and we're
going to continue and the article B or C
notify the collusion and we are climbing
on the questioning side of things
evening - not really no beyond two hours
so we would intercept round out 9
o'clock that's nothing so and we were on
that instance before that and that's
Ronnie after question in theory you will
be taking a break where the cookie
the ultimate refreshing jobs very
quickly and privately reviews return
back to the chamber to either make
incision on the proper object you had
enough information so that
recommendation forward to Council or
whether or not you agree with it and you
either do that one another even as an
operation find out more information or
that individual if you have further
meeting to discuss the options they're
being given tonight
so you might just take a seat in that
right program and moving on to the
agenda the senior projects present I
believe there are none substitute
members are either on month nine members
attending there are quite a few so quite
healthy just raise your hand role in
monitoring
carefully and these equations interest
they're all
20
so either way you don't know sorry so
here German and we thought that you
haven't written on it if I miss it I
think they don't realize I asked for
dining experiences remember sanctuary
given a lot of society to exist as an
infrastructure
generally in Japan because it can be
noted that
and they have got it back by the way
exactly there is a microphone a remote
microphone that's who's got that thing
right right and if you could switch it
on for me please
captain tables and then perhaps posit
back to you it needs to go to Angela law
or crystallites declaration
Sony's own interest and competent a
example would here to answer questions
however may be noted that they have very
slow speak up we still can't marry this
please make that the last time we
already know Martin Tomlinson has mine
mine I don't believe it sorry absolutely
the meet and carry on negative but we're
not going to the public please
you could not check out to do contingent
that and one of the sources lead but
without one see there's a lot just there
with you can't even answer is and turn
the money over here and don't question
however may be nervous
okay Justin mind and Italy intended
seating and the petition was that the
council should refuse to place homeless
living persons in frantically Oxford and
parents rate slots in radius this is the
custard for council encounter resolution
was it review committee carried out an
investigation into the neck done brings
recommendation tractable Council and
firstly to thank everybody for attending
that was invited to attend including
members very actively campaign can
happen and we'd appreciate or group of
visit from the appreciate you can upload
on previous evening to answer the
question we'll make a start from
University I started sewing the
authority there's a few people have been
involved so if I can ask them to just
raise their hand to remove the public
and accident it's and members our
relatives evening and we have really
lost assistant director of community and
how conservative and Rob Manning
unfortunately inmate experience
conceding
convection one block one officer but not
in his absence short-run and in director
Angela Lord decision document services
can hardly remember crumbs not building
a better message
this is counselor mrs. lovely member of
safety housing and Kathleen ward
councillor Camille even modules cancel
Swiss philosopher and cancer in water
able to never forget a McCadden from
Satan has made easier to say Betances
director of governmental legal services
and housing and some o'clock through
director of housing section housing also
had three representatives from employer
zero for the resident that the religious
institution called least reporter
Richard lamb ball and Michelle reason
all of these people were invited to
fencing in the past indecision seen
happening together constantly and will
be on certain questions that support MTV
and we'll begin by asking questions
and after the insufficient floor and
remember that particle detection brief
and those person eulogy beam in advance
for eight nights and come to that you
like to answer this question correctly
you would mind your one should be
working but we Justin really questioned
out is reflective of the mutinies
equivalency and first fishing wave
satisfies the annual process undertaken
and if not could you be to claim one
digit field with your kept rowing forms
after date an ongoing matter and if you
are not satisfied I thought you would
not get that today are you survived
members of the committee what makes the
connection with
excuse me champ with other way people of
marginalizing learn medicine again so it
is done yes they're not the framers of
the paper turbulence that I think
they've been quite exterminated what you
pronounce it and what we've got a fully
inspected type of process it's not mine
arms if you feel that you kept to inform
and what would you prefer
so it's electronics itself but I just
want to clarify that the other positive
impact okay first of all can we start by
praying at the reference to our host
this project as much since terms of
homelessness in our community as anybody
else we are pairing residents motivated
by energy for all those in our
communities and especially those who
find it more difficult to have devote
time to your third question we were not
satisfied
due to the lack of support for the
elderly residents are being asked to
move and the lack of involvement of our
counselors in the whole process
altogether this just posed more and more
questions which we have chosen to expand
as follows while discussions between
actually an existing elderly tenants
were taking place where they actually
offered any legal representation
prior to be a patient for example was
their tenancy agreement some of which
was being paid for many years state that
they were entitled to remain residents
for their lifetime what was the sum of
the length they were paying at our
Piscotty knowledge I was a male
detective but any author of alternative
accommodation were they 15 changing GP
is their new accommodation of new
patents as it was before
what has Watchers Council or factory
dance prevalence clearly isolated it is
widely acknowledged that with the
elderly people in their latter year
significant significantly contributes to
decline their health and well-being
power has considered this access since
2007 when factory closed apart reporting
odds as a current flows like the fact
appears more and more been updated and
we know that people who have applied
resident aver of the last few years as
in terms of ways that won't even have
their names put on any weight with as it
being a long term plan perhaps a factory
and what what should count for aware of
it and neither party aware of any future
claims is planned this building apart
from the colors
well angel time to fight look tax or
consider this present when will watts of
power actually fall that factory we're
changing the user comes with caveats we
would like an explanation of how a lot
of council has relinquished all over
Shiva fantasy lives at the cancer effect
we understand enabled by the building is
managed by Housing Association that
cannot understand what it is not in the
form of the proclamation of contract
satirist by attender who or what speed
century we understand that there are two
places in this company one is court
actually Housing Association the other
is century homes this company appears to
be all about projects and not people
there are system to in health which was
digital that unit kept in fraud very
motives do not support the plan until
the present was already well underway as
only a few people in the immediate
locality received any information
battery housing augmentation relief in
full details of their plans at all once
it became Galibier did legal century
some quickly panicked and did you need
to believe it sixty-four households in
the immediate vicinity Article II so
once this information became known it
was very clear that we are typically
changes to the sector ad as a whole and
they naturally wagon absorb from much
wider area were concerned
many residents not just in lot Ward
contacted their local council is
expressing their alarm this resulted in
what should housing so it's naturally
good relating to dropping sessions of
the legend interest these sessions were
very well attended by
it was raining most of whom were very
angry these sessions were chaotic and
misleading and only served to inflame
the situation several negatively and
importantly created the party that
courting Action Group to try and gather
some accurate information we have
repeatedly asked for formally turn over
to the public with our counsellors and
sanctuary housing we wanted it to be in
the form of a panel with questions on
the floor
this was written in a federally that was
produced for you are three things this
did help paint a true picture hence our
position throughout this process there's
been no one that we felt we could ask
about the proposal would be honest and
true answers one of our counselors sits
on the border sanctuary unwind was quick
to offer a charlatan once the news
became public the regards of proposals
it was discovered that he was not in any
position to do so and the information he
had given us was unsubstantiated and
only added to the confusion when some of
the winds offered a proposal
transporting those meetings deployed by
the two times one and interacting quite
immediately with other words indeed
those women who attended but also had
signed a petition when they have public
lands for attending future present
rather spotty meeting little arse
actually to do this we are as concerns
the homeless as anyone else
we may have different ideas on how the
can be addressed feeling without and
welfare all concerned but we shouldn't
be included in future meetings we have
often been added successful projects
that actually learn to adjust the home
edition
but of course no evidence can be by
Department there's been too much Sun
position and not enough clarity we would
now like to ask that proposal Malaysian
agreements apart the coordinate is
presented to full council prior to any
final decisions being reached question 3
what would you propose or equivalently
we would prefer that all of the colony
vacations have been debated prior to any
decision being taken regarding any
change of use of the product so he
wasn't expected how as our elected
councillors to consults with their
constituents regarding the impact of
such a change we would expect them to
have regard for all their constituents
that our Lord have elected them
following the drop-in sessions we
recently expected our request for a
formal meeting to be granted we would
prefer parts of course we made a
sheltered accommodation of the elderly
Alienist
we would prefer the entire sites be
refurbished just a bit accessible for
permanent occupation
emergency temporary accommodation should
be provided by allocating to agree units
and in sanctuary housing or another
Housing Association but with properties
around the area essentially how do you
say that they look after two thousand
homes in bhature district why have such
a high concentration of mostly unwilling
people on one site that code for purpley
Francisco
massively overcrowded facility which
will not adequately serve the needs of
the homeless which it intends to help
but will probably make more money for
factoring today most residential areas
have a mixture of islands and rated
properties and there is no reason for
anyone to be aware of another person's
circumstances the proposal for
apartments parking lot is becoming
widely and generally known as the holy
gospel this is a stigma for the
unfortunate temporary rodents and of
course must be seen as detrimental to
the area as a whole should this
component will be allowed to go ahead
provide an assurance that CBP need will
be provided and the Watchers Council
will found a full-time warden not just
during the day at night time as well we
will also expect our water counselors to
insist that the nomination of reinstate
that the quality is for the use existing
Raley residence requiring temporary
accommodation and not people from the
wider area or indeed other areas that
was the purpose of the building we want
to ensure that the clowns website will
not be made available the Tempe
accommodation now all in theatres lastly
do you watch the council tile plan or
policy the provisions are over 65 and
how does this change affect that plan if
there is no plan with racial population
then why not
I think there are plain crossings were
and seconds we asked to be much more
counselors I am and that you will aware
of that yes get and be judgmental
separately or collectively
under starvation things around first
question will satisfy with the process
and if not won't initially I I found
that again when this occurred I was a
little bit surprised but I needed to
find out all the information in regards
to to why this change and the more I
understood the change I felt it was
important that myself as a ward
councillor I was able to port has a
member of the board at the time my views
very strong views in regards to what
residents consider were important so
then directly the first concern and
these were my concerns because I had
dealt with Francis cotton launch from
1940 14 2015 in regards to some of the
people who were there thank you sir
another fabulous building though
certain items in regards to water supply
there are homes in top of the roads and
all these things I have mentioned a
century this is prior to me enjoying the
vault after I learned that this was
going to be a change of process I want
you to be sure that the residents there
were going to be treated with
consideration in regards to many
transfers and anything that was going to
happen to them but I was also it was
very cool as far as I was concerned to
make sure that in regards to those
people who were going to go in to closes
hockey lodge as temporary homeless look
from area were from Braley from the
Rockford district and this was a very
important factor that we needed to be
able to look after our own residents who
were in trouble and I felt that some of
the literature that was bounded around
the residence was very misleading it was
giving a wrong impression and
I felt quite upset about this because it
was good obviously to have a single my
third my first on the action group that
they have consideration for the homeless
that initially there were things that
were coming out that were more the
derogatory towards them and I felt that
that was unfair in as much as that some
of those homeless people or folks of
maybe houses the
out in flooded family issues their local
fog your neighbors maybe who had trouble
with here time and then they've got to
have temporary accommodation and so with
the whole process that went through it
seemed reasonable to me that this was
the right way to go didn't I feel that I
was getting formed yes I felt I was kept
informed in response to how things were
going on
I felt though that unfortunately this
made me a lot of residents were not
informed and I did mention to surgery
that they should have put something else
but because of that things should have
gone out to residents and I believe that
they did respond to that by putting out
leaflets
luckily the resident very annoyed that
this is a sanctuary property this is not
a canceled property and in reality it
was held to saturate to actually manage
any of the public relations that were
required in my opinion not only those
correct what would I have preferred the
myself yes in our site I would have
preferred the more information who
that early on quicker I would have
preferred that again that better
information to counter the misleading
information that was out there because a
lot of things have been misrepresented
by the Action Group you know why this
has distorted people's opinions which is
unfortunate it happens and there is a
political agenda
we like that action group again
unfortunately that's that's the main
thrust over the surface
thank you thank you very much and
Catherine Smith okay and I'm sure most
people whether there are three members
for a large ward we also need to do the
same task and it might be the rollers or
total defiance that is where I focus
most most my interests having a chance
the warners a long-term member of large
water and being a member inside the
board we can't submit on with a
particular skill that forensic
examination matters so as far as the the
process was because finance is concerned
yes I have been happy with that and
another big array some questions further
on way or further
look at that and they'll be further
detailed for coming
concerns have been informed publisher
South Awards said he did a sanctuary
property
it's only done managed by century it in
terms of the interaction between
sanctuary and RDC then yes I was honest
and quickly important particularly from
the finance side of things going through
to budget planning and making
appropriate financial provision system
moving on to the two if I'd have
preferred anything else to have happen
well I'm a botched district councillor
representing ROG Ward but as a ROG of
history Chancellor then I do have to
take into account the whole district and
yes I would prefer that there was no
homeless people I'd prefer that everyone
was healthy wealthy folk were not in
that sort of environment and we do have
issues that need to be done with and it
is important that we deal with it within
Roger history I think so I would prefer
that there wasn't that below politically
motivated aspects of the campaign and
certainly in the early days the huge
amount of misrepresentation about what
might happen or not or not or not the
location and I think I want
anyway once has me
I'm heavier on whereas provide for you
as a new counselor some of this change
predated in forums electric I actually
thought at the time annihilation
I knew through going in circuit
Francisco see logic was going to be
refurbished and people were going to
have to learn that not all class nice
and refurbish it and everybody later on
through rumors of being walkathon found
out so in fact there's going to be a
change of use so I started looking to
change use and women we complained
sanctuary would be really heavenly the
residents near Francis cottage aware of
the change between in further research
and reading a lot of papers powerful
business and policy items matter most
housing associations do not broadcast to
the rooftops that they're going to
change use or focus temporary
accommodation because it starts saying
not in my bag elf Campagna no worries so
let me stop and look at the relationship
between us and sanctuary obvious one in
tune with their proven century north and
we also looked at the rulers background
but the residents in there were being
evicted it almost ended as little push
out in the road applying the value and
that really isn't what's happening and
what we found out is that we getting
bronze rules treatment procedure I mean
I can't show you the many possible
for the bungalow that is people are
going into open but we have things from
some of these people's good really want
to get out so what's the V people when
asked this question apparently they're
empty units sanctuary who provide
housing and if the unit's not building
did not have a lot of salt cumin for
over 55 waiting game now the
consequences in a situation rising
Congress is they're building their use
of it all the council can do is say
we've got some of you said they're
homeless program they're homeless what
have you got for and normally they will
either equipment with a flat summer or
in this particular case start to use
this block but the rumors that
circulated really hot even here and if
anyone said the Action Group in
spreading they put some of them in
emails they are printed and often
options anybody wants to see it and even
the first family in there are the sold
over the smell drugs coming out of place
and young meaning expensive gentlemen
cars are calling around what I loaded a
truck and when were you here that said
of the to citizens million replied and
said we can complete so that this is
serious allegation without all this
sub-game but importantly Jesus we don't
know you Billy we we basically only have
nomination rights and we give up those
with having to stop selling treats every
nomination right smells way okay because
I can't you pay me back the question is
are there
you're pretty satisfied in pricing at me
on setting ugly as you later on I felt
that we were support our sanitary
they're usually very important energy
occurs in your actions have been taken
yet entirely in hindsight I think if
this was going on this year of not being
able to swipe so something has been
thank you very much sorry can I ask you
have I simply mean forget of we
appreciate you attending you've
mentioned speaking and had to say
Morrison supplement that you could just
listen to anybody else's comment none of
you know he may not read them personally
but we are all here in season to hear
each other's use in order to the
committee to make an incision in fact
thank you we have some questions now for
countries and for certain district
councils Jay you have looked up that
love the supplementary plans there with
the experimental city rejecting
supplementary questions yes this one so
I have been subpoenaed members any
progress ended up learning
now miss you might I don't need a
microphone but if you work in this on
potato and these first three questions
are very interesting as a committee
member as a member of the Council I
don't know what the timeline I don't
know when this started and I don't know
when it's going away if it's a project
you must have started somewhere
presumably in the Rockford Housing Board
he must have progressed through a
process and he must have it must have an
ending I haven't heard any of that from
in response to any of those questions
we're talking about were you satisfied
with the process I don't know what
process is do you feel you're getting
booked I don't know what the timeline
what would you prefer
I don't know that amount I might add any
bulk of a timeline or at least and
explain it to you thank you
you can come under the most pressure to
st. Green Valley this process began and
so that will be back as you get a little
this evening will you be addressed in
the same narration or do I have to
repeat the questions they are you want
to be notified by policy as members were
aware we were all invited to put a
questions forward in front of this
meeting which you have your kids in
sleep oh are you telling me off I'm
repenting or they are you a monitoring
for archaic question customs even the
absorbing previous meetings are things
that I feel will be various ill disclose
for teachers say can't find Mason to you
question my own request accompany to dry
our circuit I expect you to refrigerate
a question appropriate time isn't going
to take it man thank you
as I've said there's a further question
later on the scene with regards to
waiting the process committee that will
answer one of the questions you have
mentioned that evening and that question
are going to be being directed to the
students they're consistently happy
conclusion it ought to be quite bad news
well I'm not watching what you're saying
I know we have questions because you are
supposedly but maybe at the impression
you're giving at work if we have to wait
for you to go through this list in
question that you know in your time away
in committee members and looking out our
supplementary or other question if we
can't question then why are we here
that's not your pencil tool and I like
their here as I have said as beginning
of this meeting there are set questions
which have been put forward to all those
it need to ask them in advance of this
meeting I say I give this reason that
will naturally be subsequent questions
that members could ask counsel mr.
mason's asked some questions and I am
simply saying that one of those
questions which is regards to when this
process commits because the oscillator
believe me is that I hate that it will
be addressed later unseemly or would you
like solves it ask it now and if you
would like like it now and I will today
sir I'm quite happy
the question to the arts but I ask
without normally commence where else the
time line which goes through to
completion so if it's an extended
question you're prepared to get an
extended question appear later unhappy
too
would you mind Ingrid thank you having
particular question now some counselors
actually which is addressing that issue
will 2013 planned on being able to dig
up the range
that we different specimens name okay
good evening that a high-level even as
Prime the consultation started on this
focus last year I was managing director
approximate and have no patience with
those actions and reason except speaking
area and on the 8th of June last year
and the border watch repair Association
has approved that we would close off
launch a ballistic
for that before
following that we mostly president as
ricotta lodge and carrot road and leg
porker
- that meets on the end of August affect
them it's the first time the inviting
apart and I wrote to you town council
between and all members council members
and uniting aware and also the local
fashion Club meeting the hamsa question
in whole apartments generally darling it
doesn't explain when it's better how the
process is going to proceed to an end
when their head goes in the weather or
know where they are going
and hangers as the process that we do -
normally locating some essence of not we
have to have filled in some results and
one of you have a good one will be
moving as human beings especially to
work with in the next cubicle
we anticipate plan to work for the
building June and there'll be a page
kind over glass looking at those work
and the initial residence
then start work to be completed on price
and your co-pilot
his boots answers or person it does
presume again thank you very much okay
so remember to be questioned and having
numbers which are directed to drinking
habit they may be to secure my point
from if I picked up the first number one
which is evening pair binder so that the
only not talking from the question
doctrine these we start by having
written here articles and price are only
five point seven five couples Russell
believing everyone probably serve our
mantra final Chen so
cleaner onto the ground further by
Amazon's generally typically productions
of the clearest mentioned director here
adopted on through director the
sacrament in some of the night remember
may also started my time with your air
back in 2007 we had Lestat transoms dat
directors include services so impatient
the clarification by the way more person
seasons have before the commander safety
piece is a little bit confusing the
happiness that sir you know we're
absolutely here volunteer everyone the
assurances possible so there's none
question to answer and will probably
become the larger share of the money
detectives were Hospital
do you want to see one
I think you've answered the question and
a relative always expose them to
particle motion cartridge and relatable
last year an awkward to try we had one
and calling possum on it of this octopus
laws that have helped us a lot and we
have one x equal to x times that we have
30 mm thank you what was the average
occupancy numbers anomaly resident
usually of the ones that encompass one
thing I though residents who were not
taken together has been capable of last
year and that point and passage from
village chemical difference between a
positive and current residents a half
years and already mention that has lots
to see my mystic Artes effective largely
requires positive as far as my part of a
lot
I shall approve more details the local
dairy and vehicle shows and it will be
impacted by a number of factors have the
need to move on to do and maybe
retention tire home
and I think one thing I've just like to
make sure my dentist aware and very much
reflective into Libya prior to the
transfer and if away from tops across
the lot and I can show that last August
so tribulations and a transpose a lot
out the pen delivered by the Chancellor
and very depressing person telling
across Connecticut
it was days are really God quickly on a
lot of my concerns that that was the
units that were not used were they
usable in other words were they were
they eat food they could prepare to use
other than being just not being here but
where they meant it okay we're medical
school y'all know they've spoken to let
but what they put a 2 in it you can see
thank you comes back on that you said
this early
or any other night by planetary to offer
those and I've units to people on
clearing away and your human feel is a
certain aspect very active on attracts
birthing in a normal ratio with a higher
ratio or a lower ratio than you expect
because we do know that most of
residence in how many situations apply
the transfers but I have no knowledge of
what the mean level is completely like
every no secret that you learn education
whether it's a normal load or increase
because of my level design collection
all those business normal people would
exploit the living area and you will
know information and I've got your
website
I should smack everyone that we exist to
use and it's what a is the decision by
only a 10-15 in potentially potentially
completely like a circular motion
Thank You questions and question the
freedom planet touched on already
which is what the situation report
psychologically the inequity of miracles
and hand on which were aimed for okay so
and I first look at it and luckily
photographs of people financially if
they were making 2014 mostly negative
five you have
and they actually until yes this would
be 11 sacks and became a co-sponsor of
the large monetary payment since why now
each number goes across the identity
project of the logic 115 day and
foremost it evokes our resources like
the fact that we have won three budgets
and the data which is every almost two
years of work
and the period for multicharts became
half times two x values analysis
analogous sensitivity again I think
whatever the second thing it wasn't
absolutely necessary
so if you have Malaysia actually we have
one property and empty in the room and
regional do percent fall and become
handy listen song written a lot about
the worthiness thank you I need lots of
deflection from fusion boundary and for
further have much time a bit more
clearly and how many metal formulations
in sight Department we don't offer
different choices around are equal
normally register there in fact emerging
where they move to so last year and
forty reference the nomination that like
the mainly and another chose to expand
social knowledge and so your moment is
into a napkin from our way from this to
reply special accommodation in rainy and
you're acting up
the resulting on other types to plan our
show knowledge all of showing persons
other side that are actually notation
no questions only one survivor just
chalcogen if you came to the house one
is going to England and eccentric and
gentleman with I think what I can give
is the investment that we made upon
solution contrary so I follow the stock
transfer to place 10 years ago we made a
commitment will be affected all off and
spinning up something you leave down so
much expanded which was above the
government recent I'm standing so and
collect them to clarified and collage
with energy-efficient at work within a
third party importance of transfer so I
will estimate for the beach that is
definitely positive and uploading
pictures and markings and whatever
subject being a building
politicians boilers and many times the
annual expenditure probably everything
that would give us
campus meeting dissipation I don't love
them speaking said about being above the
government's requirements she would be
of the what percentage above the
government requirements was the
expenditure in other words over and
above the government multiple it 50
percent above 25 percent 10 percent
disappearance okay and then has a
monetary terms of look without using
them we offer made some of them to do
different people work season I hope the
world municipalities basically really so
suppose our shadows and I Samantha's in
our self-realization we are there's
always them to their outer shell again
activity of the donors are so and I
don't have a mantra to it was I was
doing so that we looking something
object you have to be yes
then yes very other inflation thank you
thank you Lagaan person six what started
arrangements in place at site supported
competition table the young supposedly
related committed with chastity or no
they remembered that they've been a
change in the way the theater analysis
in every person nationwide at the time
to do that
about lemmings type last night
instantly and so it is historically the
between hire a full-time manager on site
with in 2011 Essex County Council we do
have coming in five all suspects and
they don't contract leave in support of
the need to supply to our shelter parent
only needed to provide hospitality each
household per week so I'm Polly notion
of since 2011 we moved to an emotional
apartment manager whose work on Monday
and Friday and delivering that but also
making sure that the communal possible
the recommended citations contain
rodenandrew to understand a few priests
outlines what agreements in posted
reference example were there in your
news
okay so tentative electronics or social
content that they will be with I
probably think this ad is lying so they
won't let go on and talk all of them
inequities they were and ornamental
captain's the one section drastic
questions on raising because it's
mentally ill my body my husband's next
set of questions is mentioned that the
safety book I original decision was that
is this yet acceptable or the workers
committee is now according and were the
what the committee involved in the
decision at all and the second question
is around placing people who are already
homeless within no shelters schemes and
wherever this one person who's been
placement of the scene during the day
July was I wonder if that had happened
at April base property renovation
as I'm typing the decisions been elected
in our respective divisions and perfect
clarity we went to transportation from
country housing and love November 2015
and approached the counterfeit and it
can be 30 motion clear - that's the
first time is January so it was decision
I'd last year from the pulse question
healthy in terms of placing and homeless
people in our shelter disability level
occasion we have done that on a number
of site and that we are using be we
probably use that policy manager
properties because we moved away
supporting potentially managing I just
as you know the majority of social
management of years ago and so we have a
full agreement of water and a drop of
blood which is kinda it's not absolute
obviously having you have but we have
these
that's just Lucas yet thank you very
much and they have a person with a
difference introduced in Newberry please
confirm house noticing things reasons
and will it based on that makes us
clearly based on previous experience
okay thank you and interconnected areas
are people and knowing a significant
piece of life will be about really home
you know here we go in and in six months
so they may be basically an industry has
see the importance being defined as
president probation suitable to that
included some measures of that before we
see local customers
and we haven't followed especially made
sure everyone has consistent information
and what we said to them and asked
whether people listened and frequent our
sessions in a questionable to find out
for a second there was amazed by
services to help you find people and I
and actively and sometimes the physical
standards being applied we will be
impression that assistance in Dental
Assisting I between rehab Union article
in total property or the necessary
working with have another animal one
thing that you all individually will
have said right inside now that is like
disease such as
visually progression silvermere on how's
the feeder financial system which turns
and rhythmic at bluejack epicene quality
between distant members can expect I
hope Eggman has lead them home ten types
of the statutory complication which we
know the home of the master tailor
detecting law and it comes in five
thousand eight hundred pound who makes
public building so if I also aging pain
for all the legal proximate analysis of
participle of the also gleefully impact
penance where the additional charges
incurred with results of amusing so that
life is something like moving their
satellite service or telephone by the
waves impatient your carpets in the
process of a new civil restoring we
ventilated in accordance with these five
sites and decorated costing purposes in
and if some units apostles lines and
sandals
the other says that if the pennant has
actually improved local properties was
called an item Titans mountain to climb
is about the one o'clock
Christian then what was the financial
sentiment beautiful is that just for
compensation and running a visual or
external sports to help doesn't move
totally okay we have to speak we are
questions of each dimension successor
Rosetta and we offered admission for
that in our sessions that the evidence
Portland's find the common area central
to project take an obscure clear policy
limits include anything in the
publication that inside my applies to
dictate whether progress and support
with packing and moving that come on
belongings we pay for that service
support we be registering with dr.
Philips amazing vision allocation for 5
in attempting that and things like open
up the diabetics with a definitive size
of the noting the telephone and personal
services so it's total active systemic
and in writing for very much 2000 census
private companies will have family we
were happy Americanism and some people
and you know maybe less competent
examine spectrum and we directly
supported them though it made about
support for their specifically for gate
household you mean after dieters with
metastases
concurrence little pump is that question
on the back of balance
say that
most agree servings of
move back
the study where they lead
is there anything in the
it would be different
only that is question I suppose
three months 2003 person technologist
opportunities indicating that we should
that's right absolutely
Jerry much may I ask the council has
undertaken a great deal of work waiting
staff and members which say guy listen I
want to ask is whether sanctuary or the
council considered whether any of these
and tenants who are elderly fell into
the category we're safe golly should
have thought it was that this any
consideration given to that
hanging up obviously at half staff and
potential housing and parking and across
the Atlantic we will have information
out and airport recommend or from
killing people or having in cases where
they might be more suitable for
managemyhealth
so agency before and family members were
involved in this project and initially
technique problems area vegetable
networks that meeting loyalties case of
a family venture and though I'm not sure
anything so in that category because
residency
wonderful a single bass
expect
and if a problem council of the
annotations to be point you
Thank You Magister
he noticed a question seven one eight
zero or members spoke to social media
sites and they spoke on the social media
site - people really that were
vulnerable people other members of the
community were concerned now so that's
why I asked the question clearly there
was no particularly identified by
sanctuary north by the council but the
question remained in the community I
have to leave and Christians well for
the meeting of my time Jay Frances forty
notable residents present during the
director two centuries when situations
with clinging mittens vary across
machine using answers cliff so what was
this using not even it's not one okay
I'll touch on this remote research
efforts like we have helped impossible
to progress between Celtics played
either open supplant flows on the same
days between
family members and carers and that
support networks when fighting for
company tennis profession and where
people run able to tab through major
agents specifically are tired for me
contacted them over away untasted my
salesmen commercial activity was had a
text me once one from toad sensitive Tom
are what too difficult for actually
attentive and I was back to the
profession directly affected and
following that meeting of the thinking
and it was having people leave the range
so recognized by deaf so we rent follow
us month month into summer to focus very
not amazing summons of that to post
actually tasted
and about what to go to another
individual requirement and will be able
pencils of information
let's giant design a wonderful factory
behavior in this platform so we would
hope residents was they actually give an
independent legal advice through this
process given importance maybe
if it is available on sport the offset
mini-comic take my chances
was the intense
quite ill give me the direction to play
commentators improvised positive skin
over not mention if we didn't personally
say and it obviously our station two
objects they're having fun and I decided
my only point system ski persuasion
really are from tama lake like Matt
Leacock case when it returns as positive
they got higher priority eternity and
and I wasn't selected specific
institutions
I
so what we didn't effective service at
any query see what happens have seen
recently we've even built that initial
contact of this ultimate Council as well
as earth
and other it was wonderful problem we
can have any type of quality
so it's not a taste
thank you
in questionable you month and could you
clarify how many options alternative
accommodation workers directly contact
it's basically thousand times in Newhart
and if they didn't like photos we have
to present with their with optimum chief
certified and so some people already
prejudiced four times over say for those
who have a visitor and we met the sounds
we cook them and about the areas for
privatization of marketing we don't post
them or Malaysian citizens for the
council the names of other social
animals mutual status commercially
available the clearly something that's
important to the success you can have
unexpected occasion so we have we have
many options we actually
and suppose is what failing to consider
Leah so marvelously perform a lot of
accommodation
it was deserting a 2-mile noticing you
want to talk about in heaven and and
every desk or tenants and I commend all
that I would just expand employment
information that have been within the
distance from possible option now I mean
are hoping Kippur
I think the tech to take over Georgia
DuPont insane in later how about some
people have actually helped late
especially people
I didn't say that positive and medicine
when their ultimate automatic by both
education and community and violent
emotion when were
near location
you
sorry
Thank You person clarification on the
three properties that they offer
for any restaurant a few jokes sorry my
pathway is a process
[Music]
because it seems that without might love
you no might turban looks very pompous
another point performance generally the
my job to provide that I certainly agree
the website review office with any money
did using task and connectivity on cakes
that we made an awesome occasion as the
keynote another episode of
I feel sometimes associated
and the fishes very clearly we want
amenities and during the graduation
graduation relatives told they could be
addicted if they didn't need that the
appointment retention now we have we
have the right we have our patents
possessions to the movie to the concert
we didn't need to fight abroad president
that exception and equivalent okay and
with in support of databases of computer
science people who like open residences
so they answered the options available
here
thank you
listen Hank talk sorry captain this all
sounds very work but if they don't of
the purpose that a fair that they would
get a better deal my property because
the property was given to unsaved from
replacements where the properties were
not really what they wanted xB you don't
know I'm not a licensed and cleaned up
and was it the fact that those Mowgli
because they could move into a better
positive a better accommodation for what
they live through
so stated announced that we need to
close the case of the dropsies announced
an acceptance we made a commitment we
lasted up to much standards which
include including starting solution
telekinetically castro not a people in
the other 17
and worthy I'm just asking were the
properties that they would need to was
able to set up in substance that what
the properties that they were in at a
time I mean obviously a lot of only
decorating property a most continuity
proceed in proxy I've already coated
acting as my one in fact move man I want
to have it redecorated orbit items just
revenue share our wealth of your shower
separate share products so there's
almost just inherently often I dream in
there billion in there yes the property
the presence of moves and Caesar was
Elias and the delays at the book yet she
doesn't
so I mean donating hands in class they
some happened with custom decoration
their popularity to Nanette way to
properties in terms of what we have got
eating party people to become ultra
standard in advertising specifically
about business importantly another level
to pay less interest and have vegetarian
out employment satisfactions the
religions that move out if not have
received any feedback from those
residents at all even share the
differently including books a cousin
that we've received written yes okay yes
may be perceived as or Thank You Esther
so and but they very much will help you
made up such great information in it so
it seems as if I hope to come a-visiting
in mine inside and Roger gratitude and
there was one as activists addressed to
and passable
if you do have understanding finding
accommodation with high school I see
that soon and another one many times you
have given me an event has a waiting
period and the question
No
captain tanner is my question what
there's obviously two sides to the coin
did you get any response of this second
side now as a basically we've had no
complaints a lot we would be low
pressing and crystalline concerning the
changes could we be the companies to
whether the change of use for the case
of safety responding to the demand
straight request from our meeting
facility what mr. Canton but what it's
thanks really injected if the lack of
could you briefly explain why this whole
point of issues and we talk would be yet
and chance Association were responding
to lots of counsel counsel and
conversations are always surprises
including country we're very open about
and we're always
Sharon but councillor Stanley Zetas and
almost tighten it with the obviously
having taken these new properties out of
our theater diamonds I presume if I
don't talk will ensure this Motzkin
right there must be a plan for housing
over different armies in our district
and work vectors that happens taking
these two wanted out of them what if X
behind
come then about counsel and at the
moment the impact return I'm Vivian
agents and also very little means
because you know I'm sorry I'm for
departments and the melded analysis over
on that one too it's not just recycle
how many there are in total but my own
waiting for shelter combination of
holding 5853 residents and it's lots of
fun
why you justify an extension of robots
and it's not
position and questions and think in your
opinion giving a consultation local
residents and I witnessed in not Vincent
LaPorta Dodge and do you know that quote
and if not why not
okay and I didn't say for the outset and
we not need to consult microcosm at all
of that part time and have been no
changes
and the addresses should be before I
have
I hope you informed me that householders
man between two paths to recognize my
life
shuttle Molly's turn up and activities
go home and leave it and keep it
efficient quality and amount of times
and we mechanize the beach and we missed
some of the local an equation so to
start we miss an episode on the back on
politics we simply allow that we met by
that the roads and we apologize
our home to provide and one of the
disadvantage our consultations meaning
and package local residents having
difficulties up an information session
that we supposed to learn in order to
help Taylor and people about from the
conservative letters have something
about our parking position about the PCB
about life and security and probably
that we be taken up into and
accountability provisions of the design
came and and also increase the number of
car parts
Thomas about that I'm small-time
kantham is amazing thank you especially
at night planning applications quite a
bit where one of the major issues is
that poor communication emission
transparency and insulation with
hindsight being filled with the process
of communication both of the local
workers my community and members allowed
these things could be improved and that
do you believe that will alleviate some
of the concerns that we have heard not I
think that's really made a second page
size when you do find in say like
financially able to spawned into
impressed by the council and a very part
of something in that cabinet area in the
way people work Cox between is
councillors labels so it's really to
allow the title passes
these are we need our homeland and we
will have information only and because
and as I said continuously like that
explanation effect that will
conveniently going forward they special
anything to impact on our nation and
people said ISA forgive people in the
immediate areas would be interesting to
know what's going on because we are a
neighbor and because ABC construction
traffic remember folks and really
exceptional community based on the
information we kept communication that
has been safer a lot of questions a lot
of notice being idea be and reaction
group and the found the confusion caused
by our information session engagements
on table like this maybe they gave out a
seven-page lie about that new compliance
has been available on our website
so and while both excuse myself you know
making and come back I said that you
have to experiment we all know having
said that has been actionable the most
impressive
that would indicate the communication
process that we flow now I expect that
the attention to rules and I expect
their motivations or destructive Heather
and I are concerned in Bitcoin
and one family major having little or no
sides
would you consider talking with the
residents again as to some of their
concerns this which is the these
concerns of of the concerns I live in
the area and I know that you are giving
to my professor festive and there will
be more fanfare than what there I assume
that they are properly if it will be
what their most efficient and which
would you be would you consider
addressing some of the issues that they
brought here tonight right yes
absolutely and I pointed reversal
symmetry experimental part of their -
ecstasy
and we have house
if they exactly what they told a
completely different attitude
but that mobile wouldn't keep
immigration like send anticipation
that would be me did you get some a lot
of solid view more horse Emily what I
don't know what I find anything
specifically severe budget insightful
openness to satisfactory houses and the
other men conversing in personally in
everything we have what I'm able to
counsel if you will there are privacy
that reference to both the castle
essentially values exactly make my job
by populating but you will correspond
with those that had concern at all their
enemies the peasants or became animals
- We certainly have program I apply my
2011 tax website and you have a
thank you cantilever point indeed
appreciate
would you believe interest yet for
commuting was moving off not serve
require to read
heart rate
involves weak establishments
Wesley Matthews
in comparison blue
questioner I beg pardon sir
if you give an 2005
and in terms of expected to the meeting
very good to me these people need to the
public legal artists create essentially
I think maybe more Carroll with the
person at money right now and they'd all
really Latvians okay we've got
submissions a living on zoom through the
future and arrangement difficulties and
number-19 we could you clarify the
intentions conserving solving ancients
at one present and animatic to have
folks that lis
so all these are monoxide and Friday and
the question aliens doubt and so that it
won't look like you can do that or at
least necessary individual devices at
several people because our malice out
that doing working on this Friday
completing temperature take that they're
serving someone their lifetime one good
boy
we have
are we with CCTV cameras there
sometime
I wanna see if we find that can
Minnesota schools resulted in a public
community with and that we would
eventually be the
and safely camera selects when you come
around it is an open port yes I follow I
thought about becoming a permanent
education focusing and you know our
advice services like endless that hello
in the district with this issue and have
one
the opportunity with wonderful people so
they need not have between doctors
offices 12 or weekend's the re option
Easton mm place the Education Department
emotionally vulnerable to potentially
what was the purpose of some of the no
no time
if you will be adversely affected
capital we will be working with
inspector to say no how do we have been
manageable ourselves be working with
help
I
[Music]
we're looking at part 1 but what I
described several police departments to
military but there will be excessive
amount active work that through that
mental starting used to making sure that
that we manage compliance between the
final two taxes
and what certain conditions will apply
to the old residence of artists with
emotion and would it be like to like
okay better
but
in the nutrition if the use of concepts
of logic exclusively were oxidation
council nominations or can eventually
bringing terms from camp scientists
see how well the frantically promoted
and have a little bit unclear about your
question results exactly I think I
probably write really across the
questions before which concerned about
nomination of the district and whether
or not Constance was implemented see
doctor authority to use a very
politically especially animation and so
they'll be asleep
eating and Kathleen Smith Mason to
terrify bacteria that's nothing to live
with the grievously the counselor say
three choruses something look you've
just you know it's immediate location
that's a legal agree captain point can
you confirm to let me just run
russian-speaking counsel if there are on
run from the Housing Association this is
these are approximate canceled family
thank you chrysalis you won't be like
idea to two properties not has become
the photographer and that we will occupy
or use that goodly to its to explore
words in the future
absolutely earning in full to have at
the moment in Egypt accommodations
and progressing if you can you explain
why this makes financial sense for much
the District Council
it will hand over that again it is
Jeremy I just emphasize what system
director must have said that we
currently had 42 households intend
reclamation so person perspective of
that if we were to house one household
in temporal correlation tonight local
cost the council 65 pounds of a bed and
breakfast accommodation over we do the
math that's four hundred fifty five
pounds over a year twenty three thousand
six thousand sixty pounds the house one
person or one family in one room or the
silicates offset slightly with housing
benefit and client contribution but if
we if we multiply that up over the
solely with 17 units that Frances
apostle odds it's saving to watch mister
counsel compared to putting those
residents into bed and breakfast
accommodations two hundred and eighty
eight thousand six and seven
hold me thank you
I know you run most both here's a movie
quote usually empty with a void within
the terms of the agreement segment of
Israel to Disney counselor gave me any
loss if they things that they support
and work on different nomination
agreement of quarterly nomination we
will all have time to be narrating the
voice for that period of time must say
that we are
the question is about is about their
backs probably not the right jobs
probably coming to do with getting
revealed best moments home literally
liability of district councils for bad
debt on the lettings gone sanctuary to
homeless people place in front of you
lives and we are doing by the council in
other ways than our duty see different
ways come from within to environment and
there will be a certain like into we've
got to council but we want to ensure
that they do we never get to that point
bear in mind you know a lot support for
tenants as kind of it
you might ask how a bad debt could arise
and see around
complete captain easily sorry Bob mr.
sister Luise Oscar how is the legal room
for
the nomination VMware has knowing they
keep time with unit 1 so comes back so
does that mean there is a doji student
council has to give of them are very
much like there to be no bonuses no
on-premise maximum aperture policy
obviously the image of the hoping to
have a some point and how does he agree
Nate there will be another aging
next appreciate our new mom and what
possible refurbishment work well taken
against easily and comfortably I propose
the positive steps and legacy that has
been very patient to have that whenever
was the complacency of relationship
absolutely line repair so so difficult
absolute opposite
20
Entergy there is an indication that some
new zealand's will be wanting what
support libraries in and promote
addition cancel entry and possibly other
agencies on any GPS satellite will be
that any client approaching through
counsel and obviously we try and
Ministry of Education be defined and
that includes support there are already
receiving a lot supporting like means we
within science quarterly and groups or
how to multiply that is commissioned by
County and they called a Akali work very
closely reading and all the details
about ten and in support bearing
feelings
subsequently their part to play too
nation
well the whole time lifecycle terms of
like member of Southside be trained to
help senescence
[Music]
that makes economic success probably
trying
ankle - that makes it and will they be
in a position to actually help residents
in their problems such as if they need
to take those people or count as
analysis which they might be kind has a
passel thank you that Christians they
will move on to consider and could we
even see verification of the definition
temporary basis what is I think we the
maximum duration and what will be the
process for each tenant on this time
compliance without housing policy need
I'll take the emergency checked
accommodation Jews kind of interact
investigation and local application and
once decisions may be topiary that we
then move sign on to MOSFET
accommodation but the reality is an
access or property so there is a slight
blockage going to become a claim means
the anticipated time for clients with
bayless plant entourage as thank you is
talking about two times
an emergency Kristensen filling will the
emergence of cortical implants got a lot
co-operation the many residents attended
see
well Olli
you can sustain in the emergency
procedures of okay sighs Kathy its
regular curious little recycles to help
to call assistance if I learn anything
and we might have to watch each other
the most
I'm very really very very legal project
yes my area most more especially are we
so we've got they're all employees not
going to be able to walk from what
happened so I just wanted if we have to
at any time it goes to a disabled person
educator is there a court system that
they could use
should they be invested in a legal
requirement what it will require
patients
with reference me there's one stop that
yes
applause
I am also constant
and will there be engineer parking
places after the 30 million years we
looked at and wonderful situation
Christian and the assumption that we
made that actually will receive a higher
financial return from Francesca to not
being used to temporarily challenge
Buddhist people this is correct mister
are you able to write in India and the
negative equity for high - children so
much as senses and text-align discover
those guides the service charges and
- let's do that
[Music]
you haven't got a gentle person them
monthly what Francis cookie got you a
major refurbishment in rain and tennis
would have been rused also a German
version will they be eligible to return
as an option and will pay the price that
can't be maintained and since I have
selected business magnate 1105 deposits
lot and techniques of has numbers as
included amount and location and local
computer
and so imperative we have intended to
carry a confession supervision for us
develop our time and hang out pay the
piper special that comes from the
factory code eventually people from
loops are having with that refurbishing
my usual clock it'll be our most basic
we have a musical
they can see
the
[Music]
we've added vitamin every day
I think the Christian community
we don't want to leave
my only victim of intense episode like
that then you've got a musical
so
that's the water penalty pathetic
you can see olive tree
with
having us before the charity so do you
want me to put that another paper maybe
now would you speak quickly if you can
touch on that it's an exceptionally
heavy and actually effective organizer
stiffness and it's either had to do
those possible spaces in it I have an
estimate it'll work so number people who
moved out of the most lots of respective
so everybody who moved out a lot because
we will
I saw people like the about people and
maybe we could without simple text
values
those back
one time
no if I have about the Commission
you should superfast
submissively first character like what
every vocalist
animal remember and take that to help
with healing with Max 2011
a chance
that company this one
the kingdom you learn if they am so mr.
Bailey but they've been on to college
very effective to that happiness
consciousness alone whether player it
has quite different and to try to get
especially people means that they have
the right when we look for that slightly
complicated intellectual that ever come
out of expected to know how some of
these plainly belated English go to
social profit profit we must people
apparently all that travel to go back so
and that they compete in locally
for the fact that we have to do realize
the impact
definitely from the day and digitized
content impressive estimated
in fact and there is a permutation
reading about the financial perspective
is read about in beautiful place but not
where they
no questions they will move on 10:31 and
how often the saintly refurbish their
building being assaulted handsome again
if they're playing like frantically
logic doesn't include virtual world you
could say okay I just asked for my
advice
so our purpose will be happy moment and
abilities my family posted
English and identity did you feel that
it was a conflict it also produced an
[Music]
award remember that painting has an
association not just community I'm
recommending captain to the mentoring
and question baby - did you feel a day
the completed interest between your
rollers at the prior quarter ouncer
numbre on 1800 education in Watford
committee launch were made by the
project and appropriation before the
patient's husband president structure of
Rho
which use the national park acceleration
in a modified version allows the local
authorities require export most of the
board as always intended that also had
careful representation this company down
government practice both members of
origin were required to have any
interests and artists are subscription
they each made a declaration about their
positions
the fact of the hospital initiating and
free content judgment aside five example
this took place at GP festival
[ __ ] was at an apartment RHA English
to the question of 3y the preceding the
watcher housing and the successor
effectively an event in terms of medical
documents of the council
can this contains information separate
legal entities on the campus and was not
covered by provisions with the Local
Government Act 2000 which govern with
information in events or publicly
available after Raj Kundra created
actually hugging Association and the
committee established by
as the it reparations eruption actually
Housing Association is also separate
legal entity of counsel and a private
body which is not covered by the
legislation we will consider
communications or members active
accounts completely in printer breakers
increasing counsel is appointed chairman
own on may of a distortion is also
called myself burning across the church
because savers and reports would be
expected are getting six months from
outside bodies and is that what you mean
by what you may consider in the future
yes
in focus
this is just a clarification really
doesn't rain in Taleggio how many do you
have on the any pension the judge agrees
so here are some here at San Francisco
if Christian running animation we don't
accomplish that if are disabled what not
to use facility what happened to decide
which or will it be led to other
councils Christians I highly think I'm
using what we pts they would not to use
sorry
very efficient
the desert - do you have any legal
requirements apply the most to
completion
century so we have snatched supposedly
or thirty
Thank You counselor and I thought I got
to the bottom of this when I ask my own
questions right now have some concern
with need to clarification I understood
from his notes that there is there is or
there will be a legal agreement between
the council and sanctuary about the
usage of Moscati laws which work which
will form the base of a nomination
agreement and therefore I assume if that
didn't happen we bearish we look as if
I'm under that president answered needed
maybe the question will emerge Priscilla
thief of the in you think restore what
was a period that the council would be
angry if there's an Operations
impressive
introduced in 2010 just a joint summer
the saturation will communicate with its
presence a little bit the cracks in the
foreseeable future I think some of the
cases all that residents are concerned
with basically the Cal Poly
conservatives and tragic rich guys we
generated on that corner as you know
it's a very busy busy thought we got
massive turning in during their pair and
what have you and the Block in the part
of the roadway with contractors or
vehicles of that nature
and I increase the aggravation society
to the Westin slightly so the new many
the sacred which would be contact with
Weber sister exactly wouldn't carry on
to work to get this honest work to be
done in the future so he doesn't not
drive my
because I think they doesn't think that
the soda bags their residential area
being blocked or by traffic liquors
they can't use either they are the
company's future
okay I'm having taken that allocation as
well so much
this year who does discussion and
and so actually there is a tradition in
planning people to
whether they'd be happy to pass cereal
quipment site vehicles and the sizes to
death
and in terms of modifying residence
program at Rio Texas to my director and
we will be updating from the other
questions on our backs in there publicly
said area and we'll start carryin a
folks every for but as Apache web begin
we will make shortly like you may know
through effective economic life and in
series based in fact
and those detectives pasternak whatever
sets out parking arrangements and also
thank you
right
and
what we have no national group you
mentioned that there is no period for
life languages contrary of the headache
the contracted usually right get noticed
but the procedure is closed it is most
totally permanent with inferiority of
practice either scientist almost right
to life and what would mean that we have
gone through a physical exercise at
least and notice may be different
or vice versa and actually we also lose
it either it will end in turn but to my
mind that notice could be given and
another provided percent have that
accommodation another graphic question
and we've been assured that our dictate
have no relation right one the first
things we know length of time that we
will have the examination right before
and I would like it to a some
reassurance one point if I must have
clear
we
and if I can we talk about nomination
for moment and be silent like five years
so the recorder is my minimum and then
I'd love to have building everything
what they'll say would be able to happy
that it does make me that vibration
that includes all Christendom response
gently and may be included in the first
question and had president visited on
nonprofit site and firstly we asked
members whether or not they've liked
condemnatory back after catified minute
breaking moment allow other people to
leave the chamber to start detecting and
what we cut evening or what our members
feel that they don't work they did at a
separate lately we put in front of these
cancel mr. Mesenbourg
Tara I think there's something in excess
of thirty four questions and numerous
supplements which obviously I
participated in well their brain region
moments and likely doing with the little
inform situation we benefited from
seeing the questions seeing the answers
and coming to sort of a meeting he gives
us also the opportunity to really focus
on what things we want to see all parts
of a recommendation at the moment I
haven't got a to you if I
I say playing open an artist to
transparency I prefer to have a bit of
time but maybe so the arts really ought
to formulate my own books and furniture
events that are survivors could start
basically how do we go to this this is
quite a very important issue with
getting it there and as we've had the
answers here tonight with questions that
are refresh and we could start very
excite African I agree with your bison
excited
and
making sure not to equate I think we
serve reasons echo a regular date with
EMI what we're trying to achieve in 21st
all sorts of operations and and we need
to
even don't like to be left there let's
do this method justice come back facing
our little
okay I did conclude or more practically
we have you will think that normally we
have recommendation in front of us and
it compares a long time on commitment to
agree that every work and one people
nothing however I think that we spent
all evening around that work with the
time factor gradually suggestions
forward that would be focused
and I meet the German with the asks that
we've had tonight from from the power to
the committee we can deliberate those
answers at another beauty to evaluate
water where we are in this case
think oscillator on the recompense they
also promote this and open it in the got
sea of evolutionary government and
though he came up or coming activating
disease raise your hand
one two three four five two five five
remember beginners revive two babies at
the local eight questions be runs one
two three four five six seven
seven
mr. Carey Billy Loomis you will discuss
and debate continues multiplayer a bit
about how certain that means will take
place bicyclists so 4 p.m. Pacific event
breakfast of the awaiting you that we
are facing a moment and what silent
building battle it will be one of them
what we will kind really this company
13th of June meeting you have a subject
for that information to cancel decision
to the point of clarity I don't believe
the building suffice so we're not
holding any more up anywhere thanks so
if we hope this meeting next week we
gather it's not that a public cause a
problem for anybody who needs
accommodations
numbers
and we're all coming at it with all my
sexy - embryo industry